thanks ego and thanks everyone for
staying back till the very last session
uh so that's a long title the short
title for the talk is
cryptographic agents which is the name
for the framework i'm
going to talk about this base ranjan
works with
sashank shweta and ching hwa uh
sridevity delhi and the others
cluster fuzzer at the university of
illinois urbana-champaign
okay so these are exciting times that's
what this workshop has all been about
a lot of new primitives have come up in
the you know
last few years ib fvfg
obfuscation and so forth or multi-linear
maps
uh that's all nice but uh that also
means there's a lot of
um uh you know a lot of things that have
come up that we don't know much about
of course you know there's a lot of
assumptions hardness questions that you
know we don't know much about
it's omits gardens with you know new
kinds of seats there
but also these objects you know that uh
that we're building
uh there's a lot of questions about what
is the right way to define them
and just as an illustration something
like functional encryption you'd find
a large number of definitions out there
and further it's not just that there are
many definitions for one primitive but
also there are different
flavors of the same or similar
primitives right
you have fe with function hiding without
function hiding you can have symmetrical
public key
you can have public index private index
so there's a whole zoo of things or
maybe use some it's uh but there's a
whole garden of these things
there's a more humane way of treating
our uh
treating our primitives uh so there's a
whole garden of these things and
uh you know we'd like to do some uh we'd
like to
do some botany uh understand that right
so do we need all these different
definitions are they
so different from each other could we
have uh
and how can we study them uh in one
framework
okay and i'm speculating that
maybe this was how it was in the 80s ron
can correct me if it's not
uh i'm just you know imagining uh
you know all these things came about
right oblivious transfer coin flipping
over the telephone zero knowledge proofs
uh secure function evaluation more
general npc
and you know they were all very
different things when they came out but
over time you know now you think of
these things just as
mpc um and even for you know
something like public encryption when
rsa came about we didn't have
formal definition the definitions came
later you know constructions came first
and maybe for these things like you know
obfuscation and
functional encryption we are in a
similar setting now a lot of interesting
exciting constructions out there
maybe we should also now look at the
definitions a little more closely
and i don't mean to you know say this
will be the definition that we will need
uh even with something like universal
compensation
you know you see security which is a
very broad framework
it doesn't really try to capture
everything out there right there are
useful things like i don't know status
sales or knowledge or
witness and distinguishable proofs that
doesn't necessarily fit inside this
framework
uh cleanly but still it's a very useful
framework okay so that's the spirit of
you know this work can we get a unifying
framework for
all these objects it doesn't have to be
exhaustively
you know have to exhaustively cover
everything but still something
um you know that'll uh that'll uh
tell us a lot about these primitives now
i'm going to skip over this kind of
philosophical question of do we even
need a framework
it's in the same spirit as why uc is a
useful thing okay
but i will uh address this question do
we need a new framework
um like you all was telling us uh
uh in his i think it does in the boot
camp and mpc is so general you could
capture everything so and we have very
good
frameworks for mpc could we just
repurpose
an mpc framework and make it work for
these objects and that's a very fair
question
but there are a few problems with that
one is that
mpc frameworks tend to use simulation
based security which is very good it's a
very strong
security definition but unfortunately
they tend to yield impossible to
themselves for
things like obfuscation or functional
encryption where it you cannot simulate
uh an in a first gated program unless
you can
learn it right
also they are geared towards mpc
frameworks are geared towards protocols
and like amit was telling us earlier
again i think in the boot camp
mpc and you know these things like
obfuscation are very different in flavor
in mpc you could talk about the
diversity is talking to an
honest party or uh or protocol that is
some
part of the system that the director
doesn't touch
and you could define things like an
implicit input you could extract out an
implicit input
so even though there have been there has
been the
michaeli pass frozen approach of
defining um
security for mpc without using
simulation it relies on things like
implicitly defined input whereas if
you're giving an obfuscated
program to an adversary you know the
adversary is going to play with it and
there is no notion of
which inputs did it evaluate this
program on right
uh so you know so we need something new
okay something which doesn't depend on
simulation
doesn't depend on things like implicitly
so that's a that's a plan so we're going
to give you one framework
um and within that framework we'll try
to capture
a variety of objects it could talk about
public encryption
functional encryption fhe obfuscation
even primitives like multilinear maps
and we call all these things
schemas this is like functionalities in
the in the uc security framework
and for us we call these things schemas
and just some name we
came up with um
and okay that's one object but obviously
there are different levels of security
you could talk about for
something like obfuscation iodio public
coindi you know they're not the same so
you do want to have the flexibility of
defining different levels of security
and in our framework they'll come about
by defining
different uh families of what we call
test and when i show you the framework
it'll become clear what the test is
and in our framework there will be uh to
some extent
ah you know possibility of composition
so that we can define reductions and
ah if you have reductions you can uh you
know have compositions in our framework
there's a composition theorem
so i'll briefly talk about that
um and it's not just that we can
capture known definitions and once you
develop a framework things will fall out
of it whether you want it or not
so we'll end up getting new notions of
you know
fe and obfuscation and also sometimes we
can get some constructions
may not be the most exciting
construction won't be another uh
most complicated uh you know hybrids or
anything will be
fairly simple at least so far but it
will still be interesting to see you
know you can get new constructions
uh for these new objects sometimes
assuming
making some very strong assumptions like
you know if you had some
very fancy obfuscation which is not
known to be impossible
you could get some pretty fancy version
of something else it's really good
it's a bad thing um yeah simple is good
but the way it works is that at least
right now to get the simplicity we rely
on
stronger primitives where we start from
so that's a bad thing
another interesting thing is that since
all these things are now sitting in the
same
under the same umbrella certain concepts
which we might have
studied for obfuscation you can see that
it translates to something
for these other objects also what
exactly do they mean you know
we might need to look further
we are not we haven't fully understood
everything that falls out of the
framework
and even as we speak we are working on
an extension
framework i'll briefly talk about it at
the very end of our time
okay so i'll jump right into the
definition it's very simple
okay so before you fall asleep let me
just get you
get to you these two coup you know
couple of slides which will completely
uh mostly define the framework apart
from some
small details which i'm going to not get
into okay so it's a
it's not a simulation based definition
but there is a real world and
ideal world and here is what the ideal
world looks like
okay so there is a test you could think
of it like an
environment in a uc framework and there
is a user
and then there is ideal black box
and what the test and the user can do
is that they can upload what we call
agents
to the black box think of them as
objects or programs
um and i'll have an example coming up
shortly
so both of them can upload these agents
and
the user can operate on them the way it
operates on agents is to
you know ask so it gets handles for
every agent that has been uploaded
and it can also black box you know can
you make this agent talk to that agent
and tell me whatever output uh you know
it comes out of that
interaction so we allow sessions between
these agents so
at this point agents you know are uh
interactive turing machines they can
talk to each other
but as we'll see they'll be very simple
interactions because they're not going
to
that's the ideal world okay so that will
be very simple interaction
and in the real world there is no
trusted uh center like this
so instead what happens is whenever the
test wants to upload an agent
it makes an object out of it okay so i
call it o
and objectifies uh the the agent
and just hands it over to the user the
user needs to
you know use it so you know to kind of
evaluate
and run sessions on it and there's
another algorithm for that
this e which is to evaluate or execute
so it can execute the agent sessions and
get whatever they
want out of it okay uh so that's a
real world the interaction between the
user and the test
like why is it there why can't okay
okay good point so vlog right now an
arbitrary interaction between the test
and the user
this is in the spirit of uh the user
influencing what gets uploaded right so
the
same encryption you usually talk about
the adversary specifying two messages
or uh you know yeah in our case it could
be arbitrary interaction as of now we
will later restrict it
as and when necessary okay if we want to
send information from
user towards test bottom line is the
bottom arrow is the only way yeah so
right now uh in this framework or
throughout this
talk actually uh agents are upload the
test only uploads agents it doesn't get
anything back from this thing so this
arrow is intentionally one directional
that you know we the goal is to have a
very minimalist
framework that is enough to capture all
those primitives we've talked about
we do have extensions going on where we
have
more complicated interaction but right
now yeah this is the only
way the test uploads agents the test and
the user can interact
in the clear plain text uh you know down
below here
okay and so let me just give you an
example so that you know even before i
define security or anything
let me tell you what this ideal world
looks like what are the agents so here's
an example of functional encryption
say public key functional encryption so
the test can upload two kinds of agents
key agents and ciphertext agents what is
a cage and it's a particular program
there's one except one parameter can be
specified which is a function
sitting inside the key agent and
ciphertext agent is also
in a well-defined single program but
there's one
parameter you can specify which is a
message okay so as soon as the test
uploads these agents the user gets
handles for them
user can upload its own uh agents but
since it's since it's a public key
setting it can upload its own ciphertext
agents
uh but it cannot generate its own key
agents and then
the user can request a session between
the ciphertext agent and the key agent
and functional encryption these agents
work exactly in this way you put them
together in a session
the ciphertext station will send its
message over to the key agent
the key agent will apply the function on
it and output it
okay uh so you know that is that's what
the ideal agents uh do and
um the output of this session will be
given back to the user
the user only has handles to these
agents and then it puts them in a
session and it gets you
in more general agents
so here the user didn't specify any
input in this session
but more generally it could also specify
inputs for each of these agents
if they are agents that take inputs like
an obfuscation
okay and
okay so this thing that i just described
the ideal you know
what happens in the ideal world the
specification of the key agent and
cybertext region
that is the schema so if you're on
functional encryption schema you know
you specify that this is the behavior of
key agent this is a behavior or
ciphertext agent you need to also
specify the following so
so basically you specify two families of
agents which we call p test and p user
p i don't know what program family or
something so it's an agent family
so the p test in this case can consist
of
both key agents and ciphertext agent p
user only consists of ciphertext agents
um and you know these agents as i said
as mentioned earlier there is a single
program an agent family is basically a
single program in which you can fit in
one parameter
which will define its behavior okay
um so so far i've only defined
you know what a schema looks like i
didn't say anything about security
okay so here is our security notion
which is you know one that i'm saying
doesn't use simulation
it's called end pre for
indistinguishability preserving
security and it's in the spirit of
obfuscation if you
you know see it you know that's the
closest that uh
that has this flavor of definition
so before i define this security notion
i define a property
about tests okay so i'll call it test
i say that a test is hiding with respect
to a schema
sigma if no user in the ideal world
can distinguish whether the tests
has been shown so far the test gets a
bit as an input
and it cannot distinguish between the
test getting bit b equal to zero and b
equal to one okay so it outputs a bit
b prime and b prime is essentially
independent of b
if that is the case for every user then
we say that the test is hiding
in this ideal world okay just a
definition
and some tests are obviously not hiding
they might just send their bitp
to the user some tests are obviously
hiding because they don't use their bits
b
there'll be other tracks which are
interesting they'll use a bit b in an
interesting way and still they will
be hiding in the real world
um in if if it was an honest user of
course it will run the program e
but then additionally there's no telling
what it's going to do with
what the agents it receives with the
objects it receives
but you know we could ask for a similar
hiding requirement
in this setting we'll say that a test is
hiding
with respect to o the objectifying
algorithm
if no adversary in the real world can
distinguish between b equal to zero and
b equal to one
and the security get requirement is that
if
uh you know so we'll say a scheme o e
is in pretty secure for a schema sigma
if this is a security part of the
argument uh definition
if the test is you know for every test
that is hiding
in the ideal world it should remain
hiding in the real world
okay that is the case then i say my
scheme is secure
i'll also need you know
correctness requirement and some
efficiency and compactness which are all
what you'd expect okay but the main kind
of
non-trivial security requirement is this
that if a test for every test that is
hiding in the ideal world
it should remain hiding in the real
world where instead of
the ideal functionality you use the
objectifying algorithm
so any questions on this because you
know that's pretty much
all that the framework is and everything
else is about studying this
yeah would you say for every user or
something like that it's for every
polynomial
yeah good point yes for most part
i'm going to be interested only in
everything here being polynomial time
so the test the user the adversary
they're all polynomial time
and even the schemas are you know the
agents in the schema
are polynomial time
the schema defines o or e or
what's that again defines the algorithm
o and e
or they the schema doesn't define schema
only defines the agents
a scheme we wanted to confuse you most
so this you know scheme is o comma e
which is a pair of it's an
implementation of the schema
they're required to be stateless or they
can also be interrupted
so since for lack of time i was skipping
a lot of things about
you know state they're required to be
stateless essentially
except for this issue of you know if
it's something like functional
encryption you'd want the key to be
around
so we allow setup phase in which some
state can be generated and will be
available to ond throughout
but other than that every time an agent
comes up or doesn't have any state from
previous invocations
yeah good question um any other
questions
okay so let me give you an example so i
actually already gave you one example
which is functional encryption
let me show you another example so that
i can give you more details about the
uh framework okay so obfuscation
it's very simple schema uh it has just
one
kind of agents the agents which hold a
program inside them
and only the test and the user can both
upload them there is no
particular agent that only the test can
upload them okay so auth
means authorized agents which mainly the
test can upload the
you know think of things like keys there
is nothing like that in our first
question okay
and what is this kind of agent that
everybody can upload well it has a
program inside it as a parameter
and this is an agent when you run it in
a session it runs by itself it doesn't
want to talk to anyone
but it does take an input x and it
outputs the program executed on x okay
that would be the definition of that
will be the schema of first question
now that's a very nice definition of
obfuscation
so you know it's too good to be true um
could we achieve you know you know v the
obfuscation is impossible
could we get this uh security definition
for
obfuscation or is there any possibility
unfortunately even though it's not bbb
security and though there is no
you know simulation going on here this
particular
schema turns out to be something you
cannot realize
as i stated can you please explain more
intuitively how is that the definition
weaker than fbb security
because your definition there's no
simulation but it's kind of like
simulation
yeah so yeah technically it's
as impossible as vbb security so there
is no
uh distinction right so this is also
impossible that's also possible okay
however that's if you're asking for
security against
every polynomial time test okay maybe we
don't have to do that
okay so that brings me to this notion of
test families
so it's seemingly weaker but they are
both
impossible so they are the same they are
the same but
i have some leverage here to weaken some
knob i can turn
to try and get weaker security
definitions and that knob
is the choice of the test family okay so
so far
test was arbitrary polynomial time
machines what is the test it's some
machine which takes a bit b
it also interacts with the user and it
also uploads
uh agents which are either going to the
ideal world or to the object or the
objectifying algorithm right so it
doesn't know which one it is
so that's that's what a test is now i
could put some
arbitrary constraints on tests what kind
of tests are interested in
and let me call that you know gamma is a
test family
and then everything you know that we're
defining you can just
extend to this gamma you'll say okay you
know in pre-security instead of
having to hold against every test every
polynomial time test it needs to only
hold
for every test in this family okay
so so that's what we're going to do is
to salvage you know
to the possibility of obfuscation
okay and other primitives okay so
primitive is specified not just by the
schema but also the test family against
which
you want security toward
and there are many interesting test
families we you know have been coming
across
we talk about test families which are
deterministic or which are
you know various things which will make
sense for
different primitives but one test family
which
does make sense for many primitives is
this
test family that we call delta it has a
structural requirement maybe i'll just
briefly tell you what delta
does it has an arbitrary part at the
bottom which interacts with the user
arbitrarily
but this part doesn't get the bit b okay
then how does it use how does the test
use b well every time this test wants to
upload an agent
it is required to produce two agents
could be the same could be different
but both those agents get reported to
the so agents are plain text
objects right another program with the
parameter that gets reported to the user
and then one of those agents get chosen
by the bit b
and send upstairs okay so this
is a very useful kind of test family
which you know shows up
in a few different places at least can
you explain it i think at the what is
the delta test
okay so it has an arbitrary part
which interacts with the user
arbitrarily polynomial time okay
but it doesn't see the bit b itself okay
so its behavior is independent of b
and every time it wants to upload a uh
an agent
it actually has to generate two agents
could be the same but two
two agents both of which get reported to
the user
so this is saying it's copied over to
the user but
only one of them will be chosen using
this bit b so
b is zero you choose a zero and upload
that
a0 and a1 they could be anything they
could be anything that
that's within the family yeah the test
family schema
these are these agents are in the schema
they are allowed by the schema
right agent base came out do you think
somehow go wrong if the
the test isn't required to tell the user
or what are you uploaded
yes for to get things like
um say differing input sufficient and so
forth
you have the flavor of the user knowing
both circuits
and that's what's going on here okay so
this important thing is the sampler
it is a sampler that's a good point so
for obfuscation you know of this part as
a sampler
okay
okay so that is delta without any you
know uh
adornments but we have a bunch of
variants of delta so delta star
is a family in which it's like delta but
this bottom part doesn't
read any message from the user it only
speaks
okay so it can give auxiliary
information but it's not going to listen
to the user
delta double star doesn't even do that
it just you know it doesn't direct
either way with the user uh delta
deterministic
where it doesn't at this point matter
whether it's delta or
arbitrary it's it's deterministic
uh doesn't flip into random coins you
can also define things like delta public
coin
where it can flip coins but they are
known to be
oh you can't give any extra message here
there is no interaction
and then the first one you can give with
other messages you can give an auxiliary
information yeah
so if you instantiate this for the same
schema that i talked about
the obfuscation schema and you asked for
in-pre security
um it turns out and you need to do a
little bit of
kind of syntactic adjustments but you
can show that these definitions are
equivalent
to the definitions of so if you require
a deterministic test
if your restriction is returned to test
well then the only
you know you see a0 a1 and
maybe it's also important to say here we
are looking at users being
non-uniform so if there and if there is
a test who produces
functionally unequal or functionally
different
um programs there is some test you can
distinguish
it right so so delta deterministic
uh the hiding tests are the ones who
always upload the same functionally
equal
equivalent program so that turns out to
be the same as indistinguishability of
discussion
delta double star is basically a
different input soft discussion but
without auxiliary information
this guy is gives a different input
sufficient you know with auxiliary input
and this one is an even stronger uh
notion of obfuscation
we call it adaptive different input
sufficient
it turns out this was also defined in a
paper um
involving oops um hong shang and others
you know for what are some other
construction they wanted
oh it keeps going here so let me
actually also show you this
um so another example uh unless you're
pressing on the previous one yeah
so these characterizations are elegant
that is compact but if i
if the only thing i knew about the
obfuscation
there are these tests i will have no
idea of what this thing means
sure these uh you know
this kind of gives you some other sense
of
security then um it doesn't tell you
how to use them right in fact you know
if your world only consisted of
deterministic
procedures producing uh office
you know programs of that will be
offered for you maybe you'll be happy
with this
you know with io in the sense that
whenever a program is produced you
cannot you
obfuscation doesn't need to hide it
because somebody out there is going to
be able to figure it out
figure it out okay so our notion of
security is
limiting it's not like you see security
all it says is that
if no advisor could have figured out
this distinction in the ideal world
i don't want anybody to figure it out in
the real world so
um io you know does give you some sort
of security guarantee if you're
working only with tests which are you
know deterministic
i don't know if that answers your
question this
i'm hoping that there's a more high
level definition than io itself but in
this case it's very close
okay but if i had arbitrary ppt tests
then probably a better sense of security
here that you know no matter
you know what what do people want from
obfuscation
if nobody in the ideal world could you
want it to be like the ideal one how do
you defend like the ideal world
instead of saying you can simulate
whatever happens in the real world in
the ideal world we are saying
if some bit of information unfortunately
this
single bit or constant number of bits of
information was going to be hidden in
the ideal world
rest assured it will stay hidden in the
real world okay that's so only
guaranteed
it doesn't yeah it's certainly not
simulation the whole point is it's
not similar okay any other questions
and you could also define you know for
other
you want to tweak the definition and if
you're on the public coinda and so forth
you don't need to change the definition
of obfuscation itself or the framework
all you need to say is what is a new
test family you're interested in
if there is an adversary who breaks the
real world protocol
then you will construct an adversary in
the ideal world who will break the
you're asking how would you prove
something is secure that'll be one way
to prove another way to prove is to
maybe you know give explicit
characterizations of what does it mean
to be ideal hiding
and then just you know do something more
explicit
one thing i was trying to understand is
how is it different from the
simulation-based definition
and one explanation could be that you
are not it's not computational
distinction
um so there's a gap between how how much
uh house absolutely yeah so
if you define success as being able to
predict this bit that
yeah then that's what you're saying if
you're not going to be successful in the
real world then you're not success in
the ideal world then you won't be
successful
okay that's very little time so i'm
going to skip over some of the couple of
examples i'll stop here to show you
function fhe where you know
um the agents can update their state
or the only reason i'm showing you this
is to show that agents are stateful
okay and you know you can read the uh
paper
for more details there's a paper at
eurocrypt with the basic definition
let me tell you one more a couple of
more interesting things
in the time i have what is the notion of
reduction okay so
basically you can't have a construction
in an in a hybrid world so you are
already given some
ideal functionality or not functionality
ideal schema sigma star
and you want to build a scheme for
another schema sigma
well that's what it will look like okay
in our framework
and we call it reducing sigma to sigma
star using this
uh scheme we require a simulation based
definition because we can you know most
of the times if you are already in an
ideal world
you know you can give simulation based
security definition so we just
you know require that we don't really
need this for uh
for whatever purpose we define reduction
for and the purpose we define reduction
for is
the composition if you have a reduction
from sigma to sigma star
and if you have a scheme for sigma star
which is this o stereo star
we can put them together in the most
natural way and the compose scheme
will be a secure scheme according to our
definition
they are better than me
okay that seems to work um
and composition theorem as it is stated
here only works for the
full-fledged in pre-security which means
you have to consider all test family or
polynomial time tests
but if you want to work with us
restricted
stress family you will need a better
notion of reduction which has additional
requirements
we have such a notion of reduction for a
few um
you know classes like delta and delta
surf for which we can again prove a
composition theorem
and i'll just point out one thing which
is
uh speaks to a question that you all was
asking yesterday
that is there a notion of obfuscation
you could use you know where
natural constructions would you know
work you don't have to go through a lot
of
puncturing and so forth and still it's
not known to be impossible
okay so delta uh
independence such a notion it's stronger
than you know for obfuscation it's
stronger than dio
so there are impossible data source but
as far as we know so far there's no
impossibility
okay so here is a construction for fe
based on such a notion of obfuscation so
simplest thing you could imagine
you want to you know up create a key
agent
the algorithm is just to put a signature
on it and
you want to create a ciphertext agent
the
uh algorithm given that you have a
frustration is to upload a pronounce to
obfuscate the following program what
does the program do
it will verify a signature and if the
signature signature on the function if
it's good
runs a function on it and the message
under turns it okay this in fact
is similar to a construction uh
by you know uh boil at all uh
from last year except they needed
something more complicated than
just signatures because they were not
using uh our
you know this delta into pre-secure
of discussion but only a delta star
which is this obfuscation
one other thing in that spirit
okay uh is okay there's an i'll just
rush through this and there's another
construction which is for function
hiding functional encryption which is
similar
i'll skip that i'll skip that
and i'll just mention that some new work
where we have theorem which extends
a result of
bhitansky at all um and actually it
shows that it's not it was not a result
it was a result about obfuscation of two
kinds but
it turns out it's not a resultable
obfuscation per se
it is a it's a result that holds for all
schemes okay
um and it kind of we can clean up the
proof a little bit also
all right so yeah a new framework and
hopefully you
have use for it and um
yeah that's it
oh